The results of the analysis are 3 magnolias, they're not red today,
and it's okay to say no to the warfare of intelligence agents from other countries.
Well then, there's nothing wrong. It would be
safer for the Federation to dispose of them all together, but that would be a foolish price to pay.  At the very least, I want the Federation to be
right.
That
's what people think of as an ideal. If we
don't put an end to this kind of sensor, the Constitution will
never abandon our comrades who fight together
.  The very thing that escaped the sale Raoh
Fold I'm trapped in a cage of mercy Clogged
or
treated Intensify at your nose
Survive That
's the best place to choose from now on Understood, the
screening mourned